Hey guys, welcome to a brand new video.
Uh today I'm going to be going over five
of my favorite mid-level money makers.
Now these are going to be between the
levels of 50 and 70, something like
that. I know specific boundary, but I'm
not going to be including things like
Zaros, uh raids, or high-level slayer,
nothing like that. Just kind of
reasonably achievable money makers that
won't take you hundreds and hundreds of
hours to achieve. Here are my stats
right now. Most of them aren't super
high, although my mage and range are a
bit later. So to start off at number
one, uh something I've been doing a lot
lately is actually killing the Deranged
Archaeologist. Uh it's a new boss that I
got released with Fossil Island. Uh it's
not super hard to kill. You don't really
need high stats, but you'd probably
require 60 to 70 magic. 75 would be
ideal for having a trident, but you
could probably kill it with Iban's blast
as well. I just have some basic magic
gear. I mean, I do have the tormented
bracelet, uh which I probably should get
eternal boots. Anyway, don't kill me.
But honestly, just max out as much magic
as you can get with your gear, and it'll
most likely be enough. Now the quickest
way to get there is just with a Digsite
pendant. Otherwise, you'll have to take
the fossil barge, uh which is a little
bit more of the way, but you're just
going to go right to Fossil Island. And
once you have unlocked the mushroom
teleportation method, you can get there
very quickly. Now for my inventory, I'm
just bringing some food. I'm just going
to do four prayer potions worth of kills
so you can kind of see the loot. Uh
you'll need an axe, and a stamina
potion, and a anti-poison. Once you're
at the magic tree, you're going to need
to go to the sticky
Uh if you want to look at a couple other
methods to get here, I will leave a link
in the video for how I got here
originally, and if you don't actually
have the pendant. So from here, you just
need to run down, and you're going to
need to chop through these uh tendril
vines here. Uh there is a annoying thing
here, but it's not that big a deal. Once
you get through, you won't have to deal
with them anymore. Run a little bit
south, and you can see him just right
here. Okay, I'm getting extremely lucky.
I've only killed him
five times. I got two onyx bolt tip
drops in a row. I CC'd it one point and
then another one and uh then we got just
a rune two-hander. So, I will show you
what I got from 100 kills cuz it's a
little more
uh
important because just a random sample
size of five kills isn't that important.
But anyway, just Okay, this is a bad
example. I ran the wrong way.
Uh
but as far as how to kill him, he's very
simple. He's just like the other crazy
archaeologist. Uh you just put on
protect from range and essentially just
have to wait for him to say uh learn to
read and then you have to dodge the
books. I find it easiest if you just
stay here in the middle uh cuz then you
have more room to duke around. And once
the books hit the ground, there will be
another explosion and then once that's
done, you just run back into the middle.
Uh he spawns up here, so it's very easy
to just get him right here and then you
just wait for him to say it and you
dodge any direction. Doesn't really
matter. Uh but sometimes he'll hook you
a curveball and the books will kind of
go in a random direction. Uh but that's
why you bring some food just in case he
takes some damage. Uh but his drop table
is very good, I think, anyway. He drops
a lot of rune items.
Uh sometimes, obviously, onyx bolt tips
and a lot alchables like rune at limbs
and uh stuff like that.
Uh but yeah, I'll put the uh loot from
100 kills on screen. Uh but here is my
loot just from I guess like six kills.
Very good and extremely lucky.
I actually think this is seven kills.
But 107k. Uh so, this usually comes in
at about 400 or 500k an hour once you
take off the cost of supplies.
And uh coming in at number four is
collecting mort myre fungus. This can be
done at a very low level and uh has
better methods available once you get to
a higher level. Uh when I'm to be using
today, you're going to require 50
construction. Ideally, you'd have the
hard Morytania diary done, but you
really don't need that. Uh you will need
to do
uh Nature Spirit and Priest in Peril.
And if you don't have access to your
home, you'll need to have completed
Fairy Tales part two to have access to
the fairy rings. But I find this method
a little bit quicker and I just kind of
prefer it. So what we're going to start
off by doing is just teleporting
uh, to your house.
Uh, now from here you're going to have
to have installed a Kharyrll Teleport,
uh, which will require 50 Construction.
Uh, now I just chucked it up here cuz
why not? Now, uh, you will need to go
bank pretty frequently with this, but
from now we're just going to head to the
Mort'ton area. So I just run because
it's very close from the Kharyrll
Teleport. And having graceful is
obviously going to be helpful, but you
can just use stamina potions and you'll
be good to go. Okay, you just come down
to this gate. There is a selection you
can make it so it never pops up with
this stupid message again. And from here
you're just going to cast bloom. I just
do it on these two logs cuz it's very
close and honestly, uh, with the hard
diary you don't really need the triple
log unless you have extremely low prayer
level which is not very common. Okay,
once you have a full inventory you just
pop teleport tab. If you need prayer,
you can run up to an altar if you have
it in your house. Otherwise, I just run
back to the Kharyrll portal just cuz why
not? It's right close to a bank and
you're already in the area you need to
be. You bank it and you're done. With
this method, uh, you can get anywhere
between 1,000 and 1,100 Mort'ton fungus
an hour.
Uh, the current price is 650 you're
looking at about 700k an hour. Uh, minus
a little bit for house teleport tabs.
Now coming in at number three is
actually making unfinished potions. Now
this has been one of my favorites for
quite a while. It's easy to do, doesn't
have a high herbal requirement,
uh, but it does vary based on what
potion you're doing. Right now we're
doing avantoe which I believe is 50
maybe? Let's see. Oh, do I even have
enough?
Okay, I'm pretty sure it's 53 or
something. Anyway, all you have to do is
buy, uh, cleaned herbs off the Grand
Exchange with water
and uh, you combine them into the
unfinished potion for often a 100 to 200
GP margin. I checked it right now. It
looks like Avanto has a 200 GP margin.
As we can see here, Avantos, you could
buy them for 2451 and sell the
unfinished potion for 2654.
Now, another easy way to look up these
things is actually on GE Tracker. They
have an unfinished potion calculator.
Very handy if you happen to have GE
Tracker Premium.
If you haven't heard of them, they are a
sponsor of mine. There will be a link in
the description for that. Okay, so let's
go ahead and combine these 500 herbs and
we'll see how long it takes. I'm
guessing about 15 minutes, but we'll
see. Okay, so we ended up combining all
the potions and we sold them off for
pretty much just 100k profit. And that
only took about 15 minutes, so that's
about 400k an hour. Now, the only reason
I'm putting this this far up here is
pretty consistently you can get uh 700
to 800k an hour, even more. In the video
I originally made ages ago, I got 1.3
mil. And it really just depends on the
price of the herbs and the margin
between the unfinished potion and the
herb.
Uh it varies so much that there isn't
really a fixed money per hour, but it
can get very high up there and it's a
very easy method and really has a very
low requirement cuz 56 herb lore
really doesn't take that long. Herb lore
levels go by very quick. It's a little
pricey, but really not that big a deal
and you can really stand to make a ton
of money uh combining unfinished
potions. Coming in at number two is
creating saplings out of seeds. Now,
this is a very easy method to do and you
only need a certain amount of farming
level. All you need is the ability to
plant a regular seed. So, it's either
going to be fruit trees or regular
trees. Uh so, once you have 50 farming
or something like that, uh you can do
quite a few of these. So, what I have
right now are uh willow seeds. It can be
done at level 30, I believe. Uh, we
should buy 100 of them really quickly
just so I can show you how it's done.
Uh, so what you need is a gardening
trowel, uh, you need your seeds, and
some filled plant pots which you can buy
off the Grand Exchange or from a
gardening shop. At this point, you just
need to pretty much click them together.
Uh, there's kind of some debates on
what's the most efficient way to do
this, but uh, some people say if you
double click, it's better. Uh, which
might be true, I don't know. But either
way, it's really not that time-consuming
of a process. Once you fill up those
plants, you just go back, withdraw more,
and repeat until you have filled all of
the pots.
Okay, so we filled up all the pots, and
now this is where lunars comes in handy.
Uh, if you don't have lunars, it's not
that big of a deal. You'll have to fill
up with a watering can by hand, but if
you do have lunars, get your steam
battle staff and withdraw some astral
runes, and you can do this in probably
10 seconds, pretty much. All you do is
withdraw them all, hit the humidify
spell. There you go, done. They have all
been watered. Withdraw more, and you can
do these 26 at a time, I guess. Uh,
really quick to do, and they're really
inexpensive. The astral runes really
aren't that much. So, we pretty much
just have to do four inventories, and
then we will be done. There's the last
one, and we're done. We've done the
whole process of turning seeds into
saplings. Now, all we have to do is wait
about 5 minutes for them to mature, and
then you just sell them back.
So, when I was doing that, I was just
doing it live. So, you can see exactly
how long it took me to do it. It took
like 3 minutes, honestly, to do 100 of
these if you have the lunars. Otherwise,
it takes like twice as long, or a little
bit less, even.
Uh, so the time mainly here is waiting
for items to sell, as well as waiting
for the saplings to mature, but really
if you have a bunch of seeds lined up,
that's not even that big a deal cuz you
just move on to the next seed while the
other one matures. Anyway, uh we're
selling these for 839 and we bought them
for 760.
Uh for generous and said that took
5 minutes, that means that we can
multiply by 12 and get about 1 mil an
hour
just for this item. Now, if we do with
more expensive seeds, it works out to
even higher
uh profit per hour. You do need a little
bit of planning as the limit on the
seeds are only 200. So, you either have
to wait a bit in advance or buy a
diverse group of seeds. If it wasn't for
that, I would probably put it at number
one, but uh because of that I'm just
going to toss it at number two.
Okay, guys, and coming in at number one
is my favorite method, which is Barrows.
It's kind of the
uh iconic mid-level money-making method.
You can do it
at like 50 or 60 magic, but the higher
level you go, the more profitable it
gets.
Uh so, currently I have a pretty
decently high magic level for it. At
this point, I'm not going to be getting
much quicker runs beyond getting better
at it and possibly getting a few pieces
of better gear. Uh but unfortunately,
just because I don't want to make this
video in super long, it's not going to
be an in-depth guide to Barrows. I will
leave one linked in the description cuz
I made one a couple months ago. Uh but
here's the gist of it. For one, you just
want
uh a trident essentially. Trident or
Iban's blast or some cost-efficient
spell. Uh on top of that, you're going
to want any magic-boosting
equipment like the occult necklace or
the tormented bracelet that physically
will increase your max hit.
But as far as magical accuracy or
anything else that's concerned, you
don't want it. You're just going to wear
your best defensive gear as well as
bringing a range switch.
Uh and I'm just going to teleport there.
Now I'm just going to highly recommend
using Barrows tabs. It's two or three K
per tab, but so much quicker, so much
easier, and it's just more
cost-efficient, I believe. So the money
per hour here ranges from
500 K to 1 mil an hour. Now this depends
on a couple different factors. The
biggest one is if you have completed the
Mortania hard diaries.
If you have, then it will pretty much
boost your money per hour by about 200
or 300 K just based on the rune drops,
which make up the bulk of your
consistent profit. Of course, you want
to get lucky and get items, but the rune
drops are going to be what gets you
most of your money, to be honest. In an
hour you're going to get maybe 300 or
400 K worth of
Barrows equipment on average, and 600 K
worth of rune drops. So it's pretty
important to get that, but it's not
necessary at all. Without it, you could
probably get upwards K an hour with
average luck.
But with the diaries, you're looking at
more like a mil. Okay, so a couple extra
tips I can throw in here is you always
want to keep moving. Now the way I do
the Barrows is I do it in a clockwise
fashion. So I'll go from Dharok
clockwise around the center, and then
eventually do Ahrim's last. I do it cuz
I feel like it's the most efficient
running route. I don't really base it
too much off of what the brothers do,
except I always want to do Dharok first,
because if you get stuck doing Dharok
and you don't have prayer, you're going
to not have a very good time.
So speaking of that, that's why I bring
one prayer potion to the tunnel, since
we'll be restoring our prayer every time
at the Duel Arena.
It's best to just bring one prayer
potion in case you get stuck with Dharok
in the tunnel, cuz you will need prayer
for him, unlike any of the other
brothers. Oops, need to switch here.
None of these once you get a reasonable
high mage or range or any problem at
all. But of course, if you're kind of a
mid-level or lower level uh you will
need to be paying attention to your
prayer and making sure that uh you
aren't tanking the brothers too much.
Now one other thing I could have brought
and I should mention is a salve amulet.
I do actually have it. I just often
times forget it. The only thing it's
really going to help you with is getting
kill count in the tunnel. But since that
is a fairly large portion of the barrows
run
it's definitely worth bringing. You just
wish to it when you're underground with
your blowpipe. Speaking of which using
the blowpipe to get the kill count,
while it does cost more money, it is
drastically quicker. So I would highly
recommend uh getting the kill count with
the blowpipe. Uh cuz otherwise you will
be taking quite a bit longer with a
dragon sim or a blowpipe or something
like that. So you always want to be
moving through the tunnel. Uh
you will need to be moving through to
get exactly three skeleton kills cuz
those will get you the perfect amount of
percentage to max out your reward. At
least from a GP standpoint. Uh getting
88% and that is exactly what three
skeletons gives you. Uh will give you
the max amount of runes uh which is what
you're looking for.
Uh so you just need to kind of memorize
the puzzle. It just go look it up on the
wiki. It it takes a little while but
it's not that big a deal.
Uh let's switch back to our melee gear
and we're going to kill the rock which I
believe is in this chest. So yeah,
obviously that was just a ridiculously
barebones guide to barrows. Uh just
might decide to do a run just to see
what I got for the video. But yeah,
about 1 mil an hour if you uh have all
the requirements for the diaries and
whatnot done. And about 750k if you
don't. So maybe I'll get something
extremely good just for this one chest.
And would you know? Nothing. But while
I'm at it here, I will put a uh 1-hour
loot on screen just so you guys can see
uh what you can expect. But I mean that
wasn't the greatest rune drop, but it's
still blood runes, still chaos runes,
still about a 50k run, which is pretty
average. All right, guys. I hope you
enjoyed my top five mid-level
money-making guides. Hopefully, you
learned something. If you did enjoy the
video, don't forget to toss a like. If
you didn't,
you're going to dislike it anyway, so I
don't need to say anything. All right,
guys. Thanks for watching. I will see
you in the next video.